the right is is allergic to the notion
of Authority or submission to just
Authority but you know it's right there
in the Bible I mean St Paul tells first
of all it's throughout the Old Testament
but then St Paul tells us the Civil
Authority is put there by God for your
good the law is good order is good
there's nothing unchristian about
wielding political power in a just way
and yet many in the church seem to think
that there is I know there's a lot of
people that actually say we shouldn't be
involved in politics we shouldn't be
involved in anything we just going to be
in church clapping hands every Sunday
praising and that's it while the enemy
right there no I believe we should we
shouldn't just be even taking the
government we should be taking the media
we should be taking we should be taking
everything yeah for Jesus right why
wouldn't why wouldn't we I mean this is
because what the the Liberals would say
is well you know you you sound power mad
or you sound driven I think well
someone's going to run the media